في منزل أنثى الأرنب   دق دق الباب
دق دق دق
من بالباب
إفتحوا لي أنا تيتة *** سأقص عليكم حدوتة
إفتحولي فقط الباب
لا لن نفتح باب الدار *** نعرفك الذئب الغدار
ماما قالت ألا نفتح ***  أبدا أبدا مهما صار
في منزل أنثى الأرنب   دق دق الباب
دق دق دق
من بالباب
جئت أنا جارتكم مرمر***  لتعيروني بعض السكر
افتحولي هيا الباب
لا لن نفتح باب الدار ***   نعرفك الذئب الغدار
ماما قالت ألا نفتح  ***   أبدا أبدا مهما صار
في منزل أنثى الأرنب   دق دق الباب
دق دق دق
من بالباب
أنا قرد الغابة ميمون *** من يدخلني له بالون
إفتحولي هيا الباب
لا لن نفتح باب الدار *** نعرفك الذئب الغدار
ماما قالت ألا نفتح *** أبدا أبدا مهما صار
في منزل أنثى الأرنب   دق دق الباب
دق دق دق
من بالباب
أنا أرنوب آكل جزرا ***  ذو الفائدة يقوي النظر
إفتحوالي يا أصحاب
أهلا ذئب ماذا تريد... ***   بلقائك أنا جد سعيد
يا غدار أنا أنصحك ***   أن تجري الآن لبعيد
هاهاها يا غدار